Transcriber: Eman Abdellatif
المدقّق: Yomna Mohamed
(تصفيق)
بالطبع، يعرف جميعنا محمد صلاح.
لاعب الكرة الشهير.
دعوني أحدثكم عنه قليلاً.
كان محمد صلاح لاعب كرة،
يلعب في نادي المقاولون العرب.
نادي درجة أولي بمصر، وله مكانته.
كان حلمه أن يلعب بنادي الزمالك
منذ صغره،
وهو مشجع لنادي الزمالك.
وحلم حياته أن يلعب لنادي الزمالك.
بالطبع قال لهم اريد اللعب في نادي الزمالك.
فقال له النادي: نعتذر
نادي الزمالك كبير عليك.
مازلت لاعباً في نادي المقاولون العرب.
فيما معناه أن نادي الزمالك كبير عليك،
لا يمكنك اللعب فيه.
هل سألنا أنفسنا أين محمد صلاح الاّن؟
في نادي روما الإيطالي أعرق أندية العالم.
تخيل محمد صلاح لو أراد اللعب لنادي الزمالك،
وقالوا هذا التعليق ورفضوك رفضا شديدَا
لقد تدمر أمامي حلم حياتي.
عمل محمد علي تطوير نفسه وتمرن.
ولم يتلفت لهذا الرفض.
وانتقل من المقاولون لبازل السويسري،
ثم لفيروتينا الايطالي ثم تشيلسي الانجليزي،
ثم لنادي روما الايطالي.
كان يلاعب كريستنيانو رونالدو أول أمس.
لو كنتم قد شاهدتم المباراة؟
لم ييأس كالعادة.
وهناك لاعب اّخر يُدعى النني لو تعرفوه؟
كان لديه 16 عاماً
وكان يلعب في النادي الأهلي.
كانت بدايته أفضل فهو يلعب لنادي الأهلي.
لكن عندما وصل لسن الـ18 عاماً
اعتذر له النادي.
بأنه لن يستطيع مواصلة اللعب هنا.
لقد استغنوا عنه بدون أسباب.
أين هو النني الاّن؟
في أرسنال الانجليزي.
واحد من أعرق أندية انجلترا.
هل سألنا أنفسنا يومَا ؟
ماذا فعل هؤلاء في حياتهم وكيف فكروا؟
بعيدَا عن محمد صلاح والنني فهم نجوم كبار.
سأتحدث اليكم عن لاعب كرة أيضَا.
يقف معكم انه أنا ضياء محمد.
كنت ألعب في نادي الاتحاد في الأسكندرية.
كنت أيضَا ناشئ صغيرًا.
وطردوني من الفريق لقولهم أني لا أستطيع
لعب الكرة ولم تكن هده الحقيقة.
ولكن كانت هناك أسباب اّخري.
فهم يريدون اشراك ابن أحدهم وهكذا.
فطردوني فانتقلت من اللعب
في الشارع للنادي وعندما طردوني عدت
إلى الشارع مرة أخري.
ولم أيأس.
تمرنت ولعبت كرة مع أصدقائي
قي دورات رمضانية، وأشياء من هذا القبيل
ظهر حينها رونالديليو اللاعب البرازيلي.
لو تعرفونه
كان يقوم بحركات جميلة جدَا بالكرة.
بجانب أنه يلعب في منتخب البرازيل.
وبرشلونة أعرق أندية العالم.
كان لدية حركات في التمرين.
يضع الكرة علي رأسه ويخلع التيشرت.
ويلف الكرة علي قدماه مرتين.
حركات مانت تدهش العالم كله.
والعالم كله يتمني تقليده.
وقامت الشركات الرياضية بأخذه في الاعلانات.
كوسيلة إعلامية
واشتهر جدا بهذه الحركات
وسُجلت باسمه.
فنظرت اليه وقلت ما الذي ينقصني عنه؟
فهو لاعب كرة وأنا أيضَا كذلك.
يتبقي الحركات لذا سأتمرن
لأتقن هذه الحركات.
نزلت الشارع واشتريت حذاء وكرة.
هيا لنبدأ بتقليد حركات رونالدنيو.
ألف الكرة أول لفة فلم تصيب.
لم تكن بداية موفقة معي.
أضع الكرة علي رأسي فتقع.
وواظبت علي التمرين.
وفجأة أتقنت كل حركات رونالدينو تمامَا.
ووجدت ناس يتلفون حولي في دائرة في الشارع.
يقومون بتصويري ويصقفون لي.
ويشجعوني علي أن أكمل الحركات.
فتعجبت وقلت: "ماذا؟"
أصبحت لا أدرك شيئَا.
وقال لي أحدهم: "ما هذا؟"
أنت تلعب لعباً حراً.
فتعجبت وقلت له: "ما هذا؟"
فقال لي: " لعب حر مثل حركات رونالدينيو."
قلت: " نعم ،هي حركاته
ولكن ما هو اللعب الحر؟"
قال لي: "هذه اللعبة."
فاكتشفت أني ألعب لعب حر قبل أن أعرف ما هو.
بعد أن أتقنت حركات رونالدينيو بدأت أخترع
حركات أخري.
فهو يضع الكرة علي رأسه فأضعها علي أذني،
ثم علي أذني اليسري،
ثم علي عيني.
حركات غريبة
واكتشفت ما هو اللعب الحر.
فتصفحت اليوتيوب ووجدت أنه كالخيال.
ناس يفعلون حركات غريبة بالكرة.
فتعجبت وقلت هذا مستحيل.
أن يقوم ناس بهذه الحركات.
فبعد أن أتقنت حركات رونالدينيو.
اتجهت لحركات الأخرين.
فهؤلاء يحركون الكرة وهم جالسون.
وأيضَا وهم نائمون علي ظهورهم.
ودخلت عالم اللعب الحر وأتقنت كل الحركات.
ولم أجد فيديوهات أو حركات جديدة.
بدأت أبحث عن اللعب الحر.
ما هو اللعب الحر؟
اكتشفت أنه الأسلوب الحر.
أي شئ تفعله بطريقتك الخاصة.
ليست محددة فقط لكرة القدم.
يوجد لعب حر في السلة والغوص والتزلج.
أي شئ تفعله بأسلوبك الحر.
نعم، هكذا عرفنا اللعب الحر.
وأريد أن أعرفكم عليه.
اللعب الحر ينقسم الي ثلاثة أقسام:
الجزء العلوي من الجسم
والجزء السفلي من الجسم
وحركات أثناء الجلوس.
مثلَا لو أردت استخدام الجزء السفلي،
أحرك الكرة وأحرك الجزء العلوي.
والجزء السفلي ثابت كما ترون.
ولو أردت استخدام الجزء السفلي،
سأثبت الجزء العلوي وأحرك الجزء السفلي.
بهذا الشكل كما ترون.
هذا حركات الجزء العلوي والسفلي.
ماذا عن حركات الجلوس؟
كيف تحدث؟
هي حركات نفعلها ونحن جالسين علي الأرض.
بهذا الشكل.
كما ترون هكذا.
لا يوجد سحر ولا شعوذة.
حسناً.
هذه هي النسخة القديمة من اللعبة.
هذه هي الحركات التي يتقنها أي لاعب حر.
ودخلت عالم اللعب الحر،
عالم أخر غير كرة القدم.
ويقول لي أحدهم: "أنت تتقن حركات،
لكنك لاتستطيع لعب الكرة في الملعب."
وأريد أن أخبركم أنه لا يوجد علاقة
بين اللعب الحر وكرة القدم.
تمامَا مثل السباحة والباليه المائي.
المشترك بينهما هو الماء فقط.
أما السباحة هي حركات ووقت وتمارين.
أما الباليه المائي هو عرض يعجب به الناس.
كرة القدم لها طريقة معينة من تمرير وتصويب.
أما اللعب الحر هو عرض يبهر الناس تماماً.
تفعله بأسلوبك أنت.
أريد أن أضع نفسي مكانكم.
فلو وُجد لاعبان أمامكم
وأنتم من تحكمون بينهم.
من هو الأفضل ؟
أنتم ترون شخص يفعل حركات واّخر يفعل مثلها.
فكيف نحكم بينهم؟
من هنا نشأت معركة اللعب الحر.
فهي مباراة لنعرف من هو أفضل من الثاني
والتصنيف والبطولات العالمية أيضَا.
وقواعد مباراة اللعب الحر عمومَا
عبارة عن ثلاث دقائق ولاعبان وكرة واحدة.
يمعني أن المباراة ثلاث دقائق تقسم:
دقيقة ونصف لي ومنافسي دقيقة ونصف.
لاعبان، هما أنا والمنافس الذي أمامي.
وكرة واحدة بيننا نحن الاثنين.
علي ثلاث جولات.
لي في كل جولة ثلاثين ثانية وبعد أن ألعب
أعطيه ثلاثين ثانية وعندما ينتهي ترجع
لي الكرة فقط.
وهناك ثلاثة حكام جالسين:
حكم للتحكم وحكم للابداع وحكم للأسلوب.
حكم التحكم يري مدي تحكمك في الكرة،
عدد المرات التي سقطت منك في المباراة.
فهذا ينقص من النقاط اذا سقطت منك.
هذا هو التحكم.
أما الابداع هو ابتكارك للحركة.
هل فعلت حركة جديدة العالم لم يرها من قبل؟
وهذه تحصد نقاط عالية جدّا.
والأسلوب هو مدي التناغم مع الموسيقي.
أأنت متماشي مع الموسيقي أم لا؟
فمن الممكن أن تفعل هكذا.
ثم هكذا.
وتكمل لعبك
وتفاعلك مع الجمهور.
شئ مثل الكاريزما علي المسرح.
لها نقاط كثيرة جدّا.
دخلت في مسابقات كثيرة في مصر.
وفي عام 2011 أُقيمت مسابقة لمعرفة
من هو الأكثر تحريكاً للكرة في مصر
الحمد لله دخلت وحصلت علي المركز الأول.
حققت 2157 قفزة بالكرة.
وفي عام 2012 أقيمت مسابقة عالمية.
لأنه منذ عام 2002 الي 2012
كان هناك رقم قياسي يقدر 4000 قفزة بالساعة
لم يتجاوزه أحد أبدّا.
ودخلت هذه المسابقة وحمدَا لله وكنت الأول.
والثالث علي العالم برقم 5500 قفزة علي رأسي
واكتافي فقط وليست أرجلي.
الحمد لله.
وكما اخبرتكم عندما دخلت عالم كرة القدم.
وطردت منه ويأست وطردت من النادي.
تكرر معي نفس الأمر في اللعب الحر.
وجهت لي انتقادات سيئة كثيرة جدّا.
وحتي من أقرب الناس لي.
قائلين ما هذا السيرك الذي تفعله؟
ماهذه الحركات بالكرة ماذا ستفعل بها ؟
أين كرة القدم؟
ولكن في شهر نوفمبر الماضي،
دخلت مسابقة عالمية وفزت بالمركز الأول.
وكانت الجائزة السفر للنمسا في سلسبيرج.
بالطبع ضياء في أوروبا!
كيف؟ كان هذا حلم حياتي!
أنني أعرض أمام الأجانب وأوروبا.
وأنزل إلى الميادين العامة وألعب.
كان حلم وحققته وفزت بالمسابقة الحمد لله.
وقدمت ورقي ولكن رُفضت التأشيرة.
كان هذا في شهر 12 الماضي.
لماذا رُفضت، سأقضي أيامَا وأعود؟
قالوا: "يمكنك الهرب وعدم العودة."
واخذت الخطاب فهو باللغة الألمانية
لم أفهم منه شئ فترجمته للعربية
كُتب فيه، لأسباب احتماعية واقتصادية
اجتماعبة أنني أعزب لست متزوجاً.
كنت أرغب في هذا حقاً!
واقتصادية لأنني لا أملك أراضِ أو أموال
أو عقارت تضمن لهم عودتي
الي مصر مرة أخرى
فقلت لهم: "عمري 21 سنة فكيف تتحدثون
عن أموال أو عقارات؟
وكيف أتزوج فأنا ما زلت في الـ21 أيضَا!
ولكنني لن أيأس أيضَا.
ومنذ شهر 12 وإلى اليوم في شهر 2.
أنا معكم في تيدكس.
بالطبع هذا شئ أفخر به جدّا.
وخطوة كبيرة في حياتي أنني معكم االيوم.
بالفعل وليست مجاملة.
(تصفيق)
كان حلمي وسأعمل عليه.
أن أنشئ اتحاد مصري أو عالمي للعب الحر.
وسأعمل على تحقيق حلمي بجدِ
وأجعلها لعبة أوليمبية.
أريد أن أعرفكم اللعب الحر في جملة واحدة.
عندما يجتمع الفن والجمال.
فهي مزيج بين الفن والرياضة.
وسأريكم كيف نجمع الرياضة بالفن
في عرض واحد.
هيا بنا
(تصفيق)
هل أعجبكم العرض ؟
فقط رسالة واحدة.
لأنك تفعل شئ مختلف فستجد انتقادات.
لابد ولكن لا تيأس
وستفعل ما تريده.
وسيؤمن بك الناس.
ومن ينتقدوك سيشجعوك حينها.
شكرَا.
(تصفيق)